other than this absurd game of musical
chairs that the Tories have been
treating the country to uh I regard
Richie sunik as a decent man a decent
man uh a competent man a bit
technocratic but nevertheless a patriot
has the best interest of the country
hard works very very hard but for some
reason he just doesn't have that X
Factor that leadership quality that
allows you to build a return and instead
it's really what cakin said in 1979 when
he was beaten by Margaret Thatcher he
was told in the runup to the election
hey Jim there is still a Pathway to
Victory for you and he basically said no
there comes a time when it's over